what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and we
are not too far away from shanghai and
the legend of the tin rings coming out
as far as movies are concerned we have
black widow coming up in july and then
shang chi coming up in september and
right now we've only gotten the teaser
for
shangchi and a lot of people are still
wondering what exactly the movie is
about
and today we have a pretty legitimate
plot link that gives us a pretty good
insight on what the movie really is
going to entail and i do have to issue a
spoiler warning because i do
really think that this plot leak is what
the movie is going to be
so in this video not only will i go over
the plot leak but i'll go over some of
shang chi's powers and some of the
powers of the tin rings as well
for those of you wondering what my next
giveaway is i teased a little bit of it
on twitter you can follow me on twitter
or instagram and i'll give you a little
bit of a tease right now
this giveaway should start next week so
be on the lookout it's also worth noting
that some more promotions for chiang chi
have started so we should be getting the
first
full official trailer pretty soon and
that's really going to give us the main
story of what chongqi is going to be
about but
the reason that this plot leak today
seems so legitimate
is because it is extremely detailed and
that's usually a great sign that the
information in the leak
is good as always take it with a grain
of salt but let's dive in
it starts by saying shang chi is the son
of the mandarin
but refuses to follow in his father's
footsteps and flees to the united states
ten years later chongqi and his friend
katie work at a hotel in san francisco
razer fist and his men attacked them in
a bus but they managed to escape
so far we know that this is 100 true
because we have seen this in the teaser
trailer
we knew that xiangxi fled but we didn't
know that the bus scene is actually in
the beginning but that makes a lot of
sense because it seems like the latter
half of the movie
isn't going to take place inside of the
united states chiang chi
and katie visit katie's cousin john john
a small-time gangster who can hook them
up with new identities but shang-chi has
to participate in a
cage match to pay for jon jon's help and
ends up fighting his sister
zai zyling and if i butcher any of these
names and don't pronounce them right i'm
really sorry
but katie realizes that jon jon sold
shangxi
out and saves him they steal a car and
flee to a construction site where shanxi
fights his master death
dealer death dealer is one of shangchi's
greatest enemies in the comics
and we've actually seen death dealer in
the shanghai teaser trailer
razer fist captures katie to force
shanxi to give up
in which he does and xylene takes them
to the 10 rings as a lair where shang
chi reunites with the mandarin
aka his father the mandarin is preparing
an attack on the valley of the sleeping
dragon
a hidden city in the mountains now that
their magical barrier
is weakened and he's doing this in order
to claim a great power and conquer the
world
the mandarin believes it is his duty to
rule the world
and genuinely cares about shang-chi and
wants him by his side
but shang-chi refuses zai ling is
disappointed their father doesn't want
her by his side and helps seanchi and
katie to escape
now although all of the character roles
haven't been revealed yet
it does look like that's the case in the
teaser trailer we do have some scenes
where shanxi is seemingly fighting his
sister and we have some scenes where it
looks like she is about to help them out
so
shanghi katy and xylene go to the valley
of the sleeping dragon to warn them and
it looks like we have pretty much seen
this battle in the teaser trailer
they meet its protector jiang nan and
her daughter jian li who bonds with
shang chi
chang chi trains with jian lee to unlock
his chi
katie befriends the locals and adopts a
magical creature that she names
norris and xia ling learns the true
history of the mandarin
the mandarin arrived in the valley of
the sleeping dragon as a young man and
trained there but he stole the ten rings
and escaped to build his criminal empire
jion lee leads xiang chi to the great
protector the dragon who holds the great
power that the mandarin is after
the great protector claims that xiangxi
is destined to protect the world
but shanghi just wants a normal life zai
ling
is secretly still loyal to the mandarin
and reluctantly disables the magical
barrier
allowing the mandarin and his forces to
attack this is that battle scene that i
mentioned
the mandarin subjugates the locals and
uses the tin rings to control the great
protector in order to use him as a
weapon
giannan stands against him forcing the
mandarin to kill her
the mandarin orders the locals to submit
to him or die
zeiling pleads for their lives but the
mandarin refuses to spare them
zyling realizes he isn't a noble warrior
and chooses to die with the locals
chiang chi escapes during the attack
accepts his destiny and
unlocks his chi and returns to face his
father saving the locals
there is a huge battle between the
mandarin's army and the warriors of the
valley of the sleeping dragon and the
magical creatures that live in the
mountains
razer fist fights jian li and almost
kills her until katie intervenes and
takes him down
meanwhile zai ling fights and kills
death dealer shangxi battles the
mandarin they both
use their powers at first but then shang
chi challenges him to an honorable fight
which he wins xiangxi reclaims the tin
rings and frees the great protector who
then repels what's left of the
mandarin's army
chongqi then returns the tin rings to
jiang li
katy ends up choosing to stay in the
valley of the sleeping dragon while zai
ling
leaves to search for redemption the
mandarin accepts defeat and expresses
pride in chang chi
and xiang chi expresses respect towards
his father even if his ideals are wrong
the mandarin is imprisoned in the valley
of the sleeping dragon while shanghi
returns to the world to destroy what is
left of the ten rings organization
and that's it for this plot link and i
gotta say i really think that this could
be the movie it lines up with what we
saw in the teaser trailer but it also
gives an extremely detailed account of
things that we haven't seen in the
teaser trailer and honestly this sounds
pretty dang good this is going to be a
marvel studios
martial arts movie that's who shang chi
is he is the master of
kung fu he is among the greatest
fighters in marvel comics history and
one of the cool things about him is the
fact that he really
kind of doesn't have any superpowers
shanxi is the master of kung fu that is
his biggest asset but his discipline is
also a huge part of his skill
he has mastered all of his five senses
he has complete control over his body
he can control his blood flow to slow
the spread of poison he can regulate his
own heartbeat and even slow down his own
bleeding
he also has control over his nervous
system so that he can numb
himself to the pain that he receives
he's also a master of weapons
and acrobats which makes him an insanely
deadly warrior
he also has chi control or energy
control and he can channel his own
energy into his fighting
this makes his martial art skills pretty
much superhuman
and that's the pretty cool thing about
chongqi he's a pretty grounded character
and i'm really looking forward to seeing
this character on screen now i also
talked about the 10 rings and i'll
explain their powers as well
now in the comics the 10 rings were
actually rings that you wore in your
fingers whereas in the movie we have
seen that the rings are actually
kind of like bracelets that we see the
characters wearing on their
arms each ring has a different power and
keep in mind that
marvel studios may not copy exactly what
the marvel comics did and could change
their powers up a little bit
but here's what they are in the comics
we'll start with the left hand and we'll
start with the pinky which is
ice blast so essentially the power of
sub-zero from mortal kombat the ring
finger is minto
intensifier which means the mandarin can
magnify his psychic energy
enabling him to mentally control a
person however he can only do this
at short ranges the middle finger is
electricity blast
the index finger is flame blast and the
thumb
is white light it emits many different
types of energy from the electromagnetic
spectrum
essentially laser beams so that was the
left hand now on to the right hand
the pinky is blacklight it creates an
area of
absolute blackness where all light is
absorbed the ring finger is a
disintegration beam which can destroy
the bonds between atoms and molecules
causing an object's cohesion to fall
apart
however when this is used it needs 20
minutes to recharge
the middle finger is a vortex beam which
causes the air to swirl about in a
vortex at high speed it can levitate
objects including the person using it
basically giving them the ability to fly
the index finger is what's called an
impact beam it projects a concussive
force of approximately 350 pounds of tnt
so pretty much a huge explosive blast
and the thumb
is a matter rearranger it can rearrange
atoms and or molecules of substances or
speed up
or slow down their movements to result
in various effects
so pretty much the tin rings are super
op
and i'm actually convinced that marvel
studios probably going to dial down the
intensity of their powers just a little
bit much like they did for the infinity
gauntlet
in avengers infinity war and end game
but those are the powers of shanxi
and of the 10 rings this movie sounds
like it's going to be pretty awesome but
let me know your thoughts about it
in the comments down below don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest mcu videos don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram
or twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you